hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Game of Thrones episode eight
video just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen it they had so much fun
burning theories to the ground in this
episode it was crazy the biggest theory
is that the episode shut down for one
Clegane Bowl
the second big one was that there was
going to be a twist behind arias
storyline like Prabhu si Fight Club
Syrio Forel just some big twist with
arias storyline so I'll try to explain
you know what was going on with that but
then also the theory that the actor
playing lemon lemon cloak was teasing
Lady Stoneheart in last week's episode
so I was definitely bummed out by
clicking bolt but I did kind of expect
the Lady Stoneheart thing to not pan out
I did think the actors were just having
a little bit of fun with us because they
seriously do get in a lot of trouble
when they spoil things HBO is super
litigious and even if Ian McShane did
spoil a bunch of stuff they probably
still withheld a bunch of money from him
usually actors get paid extra money for
keeping secrets so if they break that
part of the contract they just don't get
that extra money on top of whatever they
get paid like they get a bonus so here
we got a top 10 WTF
I'll explain books changes as we go
along number 10 fake Cersei does a much
real or version of the purple wedding
she listened to arias advice so her
performance also tells you a lot about
what's going on during Jaime's storyline
where he's talking about the fierceness
the Cersei and Catelyn Stark had for
their children so that makes you wonder
what's gonna happen now with Tommen and
Cersei and King's Landing
given that she'd do anything to protect
him but now that are at odds so number 9
Tommen bans trial by combat so this is
like Cersei slam-dunk win now she's
going to have to scramble with Qyburn
and the new play sounds like it's going
to have something to do with Kai burns
little birds he says he has a secret
something that he was investigating we
don't actually know what it is but it's
going to be some secret that will help
her defeat the high Sparrow the big WTF
what could it possibly be I feel like
her best option would be to burn down
the great Sept with everyone in it using
wildfire
maybe that's what Qyburn was researching
like finding some wildfire that had been
left in the city somewhere because the
Mad King when he gave the order to burn
down King's Landing to burn them all
he'd already hidden stockpiles of
wildfire all over the city so maybe the
little birds found some wildfire so
there's just a big question mark with so
she's storyline you guys can let me know
what do you think the Qyburn secret is
but Tom and banning trial by combat was
definitely the biggest blow to Clegane
bowl number eight WTF fake Cersei kind
of adopts Aria you should come with us
we're going to Pentos which is actually
where Illyria lives who we haven't seen
in a while he's a much bigger part of
the plot in the books and he is part of
the Targaryen restoration that Varys is
part of so it was kind of a dead end and
you're really just waiting for the
Terminator to show up on their doorstep
and go at it with Aria again so this was
really only nice just to see someone
treat Aria like a mother what like how
long has it been since arias felt a
mother's love so like this is the
closest she's gotten in a long long time
that death reveal though that was pretty
epic it's almost like she was folded
around the chair just like Oh God
number seven one of my other favorite
kills in the episode the mountain versus
the faith militant basically ripping one
of their skulls out with the spine still
attached that was such a great practical
effect there was probably a little bit
of CG but it was mostly practical like
an actual physical skull bonus points to
any of you on Halloween if you can
actually rig a practical effect so when
trick-or-treaters come to your house
looking for candy you just you rip like
a fake skull out of some body you would
probably get arrested for child
endangerment and someone would probably
die from fright but number six now the
big gunslinger stand off Jaime and
Brienne so the whole purpose of this
scene is really to question Jaime's
honor where do his loyalties lie is he
going to do the right thing in what even
is the right thing but the way they use
music in this in the exchange that they
had just lets you know that there's
still something between them and Jaime
still has good inside him he still has
some sense of Honor but he believes that
he loves Cersei his loyalty is to his
family so while he's not throwing
Brienne under the bus he's not just
gonna lay down his arms and quit his
family and go join her up in the north
so of all the story lines this is
actually the most remarkably believable
Brienne narrowly escapes the blackfish
fights to his death this is the only way
I know this is my home I'm gonna fight
to the end so it's very melancholy but
that last little wave was just so
beautiful just like hey you know maybe
we'll see each other again someday
dan and Dave actually after the episode
were kind of ambiguous about whether or
not they would meet up again I don't
think they would have said that though
if that weren't going to be the case so
if you're still shipping these two
characters they're still potential for
that at future seasons I think the show
is trying to do everything it can to
keep the main actors on the show as long
as possible so that's why even if Cersei
takes it in the butt at this trial I
think that she'll still be around next
season
number five though big book moment this
made me so happy
Jaime threatens to catapult ed Muir's
baby with Rosalind Frey over the
battlements at Riverrun if he doesn't
cede the castle this was one of those
tongue-in-cheek moments that's pulled
straight out of Jaime's storyline in
book four Marie tells admir I'll let you
enter the castle if you turn it around
and surrender to us if not I will return
your new baby to you by catapult so
while that's a really big book moment
number four big book change is the
Brotherhood without banners storyline in
the Hound The Hound just eviscerate just
goes total Terminator on half of that
band that killed his peace cult then
goes after LEM LEM and cloak and we see
Thoreau sameer in beric Dondarrion again
so at this point in the books beric
Dondarrion has given the kiss of life to
Lady Stoneheart she's taken over and her
signature move is hanging everyone so
all the hanging here is really just a
wink to that which I think most of us
all kind of agreed was the way they were
gonna take it if they were gonna do Lady
Stoneheart they would have probably done
her during season four but I just did a
big video explaining her book storyline
so I'll put a link in the description
it's actually pretty spectacular but a
lot of it would have spoiled what was
going to happen with Jon Snow storyline
so there's just a number of reasons why
they probably chose not to do it on the
TV show but the other big strike to
cleganebowl comes when Barret and darin
and Thoros say we have something that
we're going to be doing in the north a
much greater cause something way more
terrible than what's happening here is
going on we need your help it's like
they're offering the Hound a way to
atone for the terrible things that he's
done be a fighter because that's what he
is but be a fighter for cause that's
righteous so it seems like the Hound is
headed north and now number three Arya
is headed north because she kills the
wave from OC Fight Club goes down the
toilet I am a really glad I didn't waste
time making a video about that we all
felt like she was coming back to
Westeros eventually it was just a
question of how that was going to happen
in what was going to cause her to do
that was she gonna do it as a faceless
person or as the
show total she's basically just quitting
the organization I'm not no one I'm Arya
Stark of Winterfell and I'm going home
so if you're not sure why everyone was
so confused about what was going on with
Arya storyline last week
it's just that Arya wasn't acting the
way Arya normally acts which now we know
was the show just being inconsistent in
the way that that character was
portrayed there wasn't any secret behind
it it was just them getting lazy but we
actually learned why she didn't have
needle with her because she had hid it
way down here so that explains that but
I mean there are a number of
inconsistencies in the scenes from last
week so try not to overthink it too much
it was just her versus the wave but I
did like the way they cut that final
scene where she just chops the candle in
half cut to the blood pool as jackings
following it down to the face so I
totally understand if you're not happy
with the way that went down because
sometimes even with TV shows that are
this big there are so many moving parts
that sometimes what ends up on-screen
can feel a little misleading even if
it's not intentionally meant to be so
but that music that they shut the
episode down with like the the drums
probably my new favorite game of Thrones
soundtrack I'm gonna actually have to
rip that out of the end of the episode
but number two really badass reveal
Daenerys
rolls back into the pyramid as we see
drogon flying around in the background
in number one WTF the second siege of
murine so the first siege was when
Daenerys was sacking it the first time
the second big one is implied to be a
winds of winter thing the great masters
of slavers Bay coming to reclaim their
property so I was totally not expecting
the Daenerys reveal what I was expecting
is is that because this scene with them
drinking wine telling jokes was so
mundane I was expecting the pyramid to
start shaking in the Dragons to get out
Vissarion and ragel and then for them to
just go crazy on all the great master
ships which i think will happen the
dragons will get out they'll handle some
of the ships but what about Theon and
Yara don't you think that they'd be able
to capture some of those ships and that
would help get them much closer to the
1,000 number the Daenerys needs to get
everyone over to Westeros like it's like
oh we need all these ships but then
surprise surprise a bunch of them just
come sailing up so why don't we take
them so here's my big question for you
guys with respect to this storyline how
long do you think it's going to be
before the other two dragons get out and
start going crazy on all the ships in
the bay
with drogon it feels like one of those
things that they would tease and like
the second or third act like things go
crazy
Daenerys sees drogon going nuts and
she's like okay why don't we let the
other two dragons out and then you
finally get this big reveal of I'm going
crazy but as much of a bummer as it is
to see like Clegane bowl isn't going to
be happening pretty much all the other
theories that they dumped water on I
didn't really think that we would see
Lady Stoneheart and I felt like the aria
explanation was going to be something a
little more straightforward you have to
remember that fan theories tend to be
way more complicated way more
interesting than what actually ends up
happening on screen and that's true of
any TV show that's just part of the fun
of making fan theories is you have some
really fantastical idea for how the plot
might work out or their character
relationships and TV shows tend to opt
for the simplest most easy explanations
you could possibly imagine so sometimes
that ends up being kind of disappointing
but let me know in the comments were you
really hoping that we would see some of
these big theories pan out or did you
not buy into any of them at any point
and what's gonna happen next is I'll do
a Q&A video there is a new round of the
giveaway that's going on right now all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video if there any bonus videos later
this week you guys want any snow bowl
John stove vs Ramsay stuff just let me
know in the comments because that is
what is happening they tease that giant
battle but we also have the second siege
of murine this other big battle marine
so there's at least two giant pitched
battles and then we have Circe's trial
with the faith which is the Battle of a
very different kind still so much hype
making to be done but while you guys
wait for my next video to post you can
click here to are all about Lady
Stoneheart in the books I explained what
her book story is and you can click here
to learn all about euron greyjoy
storyline thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you